[Music]
one thing i find really helpful when i'm
watching tv is that little info button
on the cable remote you know that button
i'm talking about you press it and it
brings up
that screen that tells you what you need
to know about the show you're watching
yeah it's really helpful absolutely well
i thought we'd take a look at some info
button results in a piece called what am
i watching
[Music]
[Applause]
that's interesting i haven't checked in
a while
uh let's check out 60 minutes i think 60
minutes is on and uh okay
let's check out the info button see what
they describe it serious and
thought-provoking look at issues
affecting our society as presented by
reanimated skeletons
seems harsh let's check out jesse mars
harsh let's check out dexter there's
dexter
let's check out what it says there
a show that reveals a sad truth the only
worthwhile person in florida is a serial
killer
check out celebrity apprentice sarah's
celebrity apprentice let's see what the
info button says
watch minnie me and the replacement
bassist for night ranger fight over who
sold more lemonade
that's pretty much it
sesame street i want to check out oh
there's sesame street this should be
nice let's check out the info button on
that
black magic enables puppets to co-exist
with humans
in an unnatural urban dystopia wow
here's diners drive-ins and dives
let's check it out
one embarrassing clown's quest for the
ultimate case of diarrhea
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
let's check out duck dynasty oh duck
dynasty people love this show let's see
what the info button says
former members of zz talk
do something with ducks
dateline nbc see what they say here
about dateline nbc
every week a respected small town doctor
murders someone he loves
wow that's more true than funny yeah
yeah seinfeld
let's check out the info button
you've seen this one
okay yeah
uh fashion police with joan rivers let's
check it out
half melted talking candle makes jokes
who am i to judge let's check out the
next one csi miami there's csi miami
let's see what it says
david caruso acts like a douche around
corpses
and finally conan hey there's conan
let's see what it says
unscripted reality show about a man
child and his trusty friend
other man child
some of the others were harsh but that's
right that's just true